hi I'm Lea here's my question to
economics low rent do you think that
economics is becoming more and more a
branch of mathematics than independent
science no it's becoming less and less
branch of mathematics we're acquiring
more data and doing more analysis
mathematics itself sure is used as in
all sciences it's a language by which
experts communicate precisely what
meaning is but that's all it's a
language economics is an independent
science and is becoming even more of an
independent science but it uses
mathematical techniques economics is the
study of how the economy functions and
how the economy would function
differently with different government
policies to try to think coherently
consistently logically around these
economic questions it's natural that
economists use mathematical models to
clarify the links in a very complex
economy it does use more and more
mathematical techniques because they're
the most clear techniques to use we know
what we're doing they are techniques
that help us to reach conclusions from
apparently unrelated assumptions that we
make and there are also techniques that
help us move the theory forward to offer
more explanations but but it's an
independent science and in fact it's
developing its own mathematical
techniques as well very frequently
mathematics has been used in economics
for a long time naturally when the use
of mathematics first started growing
some of the old guard were resistant to
it were opposed to the change in methods
but for as long as I've been an
economist then I started graduate school
in 1960 mathematics has been a central
part of the education and research
process